- Also you're singing with
one of my other favorites,
Dolly, "Seasons."
- Dolly Parton, yeah.
(audience cheering)
- There is a part of the
song where I swear to you,
I was like, your vibratos
almost sounds similar.
There's a part where
you're just like, "Wait,
which one is which at one point?"
In the song, when I was listening.
How did that come about?
- I tried like, hitting
up her manager a lot.
- Because she doesn't,
y'all, she still sends faxes.
I'm not kidding.
- Oh yeah.
- It's hard, you gotta
send a bird for that one.
It's like a pigeon.
- So they were like, "Hey, okay, sure,
send us a song, but we need it on a CD."
And I was like, "I don't have,
I don't know how to make, like,
I don't remember how to make the CD."
(Kelly laughs)
- I know, I'm telling you,
that's so funny 'cause I've
done something with her.
- But she's so sweet.
I had another song prior to this one.
- Yeah.
- And I was talking about,
it was a song about heaven
and hell and stuff like that.
And she was like, she wrote
me a handwritten letter.
- Totally her.
- And telling me why she
doesn't wanna sing about hell
'cause, you know, heaven and hell like,
she doesn't wanna like,
she doesn't wanna say...
- She didn't wanna invest in
that kind of conversation.
- Yeah, she didn't wanna
go into that energy.
So then I sent her "Seasons."
- Yeah.
- And she loved it.
And then a week later
she sent me her verse.
- Well, "Seasons" sounds like something
she would've recorded.
That's why it's so perfect
how that worked out.
And way to go for her
being honest and polite,
like sending you something-
- She is the nicest.
- Yeah.
- She is one of
the nicest people I've ever met.
And she is the funniest.
- So funny.
- She said she would adopt me.
So wherever the camera is right now.
(Kelly chuckling)
Dolly,
you said you were gonna adopt me and-
- You don't look far off.
It's like beautiful bombshell.
- I mean I wish, I mean, sorry mom.
(everyone laughing)
- She does not wish that. (chuckles)
- No, but she's such an icon.
Like, she's like, not only just an artist
but she was a songwriter.
She wrote, "I Will Always
Love You" by Whitney.
So many more songs.
- "Coat of Many Colors,"
"Jolene," all of songs.
- So we shot
a music video together, which
is coming out today as well.
(audience applauding)
- And I'll tell you
what, she shows up ready.
She shows up ready.
- Oh, girl!
Girl, she put me to shame.
Let me tell you.
I thought I looked good.
I was like, "Okay, I feel good.
I have my corset on, my heels."
She showed up in six inch heels.
- Yep.
- Six inch heels.
A corset, her (beep) were like this high.
(Kelly chuckling)
And she was ready to go.
She's like, "Whatever you need, let's go.
Let's get this done."
- She's so professional.
- Yeah, so many lessons-
- But I didn't ask her,
I wanted to ask her something
and I forgot, I chickened out.
- [Kelly] What did you wanna ask her?
- I wanted to see if she had tattoos.
- You know, here's the thing, people,
it's been a thing 'cause she's
always got her arms covered.
People have always said she has tattoos.
I've never seen this either.
- That's my goal.
I'm gonna find out.
(audience chuckling)
- I don't know if I wanna know.
- Okay.
- I kind of,
I think I don't wanna know
and I wanna pretend that she's
got full sleeves. (chuckles)
Like, I wanna pretend that
Dolly Parton has full sleeves
and it's just like just has a Harley
and it's just like on weekends
just roaming the planet.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what I need
to know, in my brain.
Anyway, I love her.
I love "Seasons" though.
It's a damn great song.
- Thank you.
- I cannot wait to sing
it one day. (chuckles)
I love it.